Hôm nay, hôm nay, thông thống Mỹ đông nên Trump trên bố hôm sẽ không gặp lại tổng thống ngà
bệnh việp của tin cho đến khi chắc chắn 2 bên có thể đạt được một thỏa thuật hoặc bình thức chất,
chủ của quay nà. Phát biểu của các phòng viên trên trên trên cơ cơ lực mode khi đang trên đường
tới cho à, ông Trump nói, tôi phải biết rằng chúng ta sẽ đạt được thoát thuật.
Tôi sẽ không lọc phi thời gian của mình. Nhà lấy đào Mỹ cho biết ông tình kỳ bọng trên trên hoặc bình nà,
của quay nà sẽ được phản tất trước cả thỏa thuật ở Trung Dông. Nhưng khiển mọi thứ đang chở nên thất vọng
hôm hôm đợi. Phát biểu của Trump được gửa ra chỉ vài ngày sau khi Washington
át đặt lệnh Trung Pháp mới, đối với 2 tập đoàn dầu khi là nhất của Ngà là Rose
Nép và Lúc Coy. Nhằm ra tăng sự át bộ mắt Scuba, chúng rất trình sử, theo các ngồn tên từ nhà chắn,
chỉ quyết Mỹ thậm chí đã trình bị gọi Trung Pháp Bộ xung, nhắm vào lưỡng nâng và hạt tần dầu mọc của Ngà.
Nếu mắt Scuba tiếp tục chỉ hoảng tệ Trung Hoa Bình, trong khi đó ở về trường ngà,
tổng thống rất nghiệp của tin thơ nhất, các biệt pháp Trung Pháp lặng nghiêm trong
nhưng cho rằng Trung không đủ để làm tổn hại nên kinh tế ngà và mô tả đây là những hành động thiếu tin thiệt.
Ông sau đó cụ đã phải viên của mình là Kyri and Demitriet từ Washington để đối thoại.
Pháp biểu với Kân chuyênện Xenem của Mỹ, ông Demitriet nói,
của gặp thức định mới chỉ tạm hoán và chưa dừng hoàn toàn,
sông dừng mạnh khả nắng đối thoại chỉ của tệ tiến ra,
nếu nụ cầu của Mắt Scuba được thấu hiểu và tôn trọng.